[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 el
comité de la cámara de representantes
Que investigó los hechos relacionados
con el intento de la toma del Capitolio
en Estados Unidos recomendó en su
informe final acusar al expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción e
insurrección
tras días de encuentros y negociaciones
la Cumbre cop 15 realizada en la ciudad
de Montreal en Canadá dejó un acuerdo
histórico en materia de biodiversidad
que busca proteger el 30% del territorio
del planeta y de los cuerpos de agua
Qatar dijo Adiós tras haber sido la sede
de la Copa del Mundo controversias
críticas 17 mil millones de dólares en
ingresos y más de 1,2 millones de
visitantes analizamos el balance que
dejó el primer mundial organizado en
medio oriente
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en Washington
en Estados Unidos en donde el comité
para la cámara de representantes Que
investigó los hechos ocurridos durante
el intento de la toma del Capitolio el 6
de enero del 2021 sugirió que el
expresidente Donald Trump sea acusado
por obstrucción e insurrección veamos
un pedido a la justicia el comité
legislativo que Investiga el asalto del
6 de enero del 2021 al Capitolio
recomendando el departamento de Justicia
estadounidense imputar el expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción de la
justicia incitación al terrorismo
conspiración en contra del gobierno
federal y declaraciones falsas a la
justicia
La fe es la base de la Democracia
estadounidense si se rompe la fe se
rompe nuestra democracia y Donald Trump
la rompió perdió las elecciones de 2020
y lo sabía buscaba anular los resultados
con la intervención de varias partes
para bloquear la transferencia de poder
tras un año y medio de investigaciones
la comisión considera que Trump no actúa
en solitario además de encontrar que
pasó la tarde viendo el ataque por
televisión el 6 de enero de 2021 unas
10.000 personas se manifestaron en
frente del Capitolio y cerca de 800
irrumpieron en el edificio mientras se
ratificaba la victoria del demócrata Joe
biden en las elecciones presidenciales
hubo cinco muertos y unos 140 heridos
fue la primera vez que un presidente
estadounidense rechazó su deber
constitucional de transferir el poder
pacíficamente al siguiente Durante los
últimos 18 meses el comité selecto ha
reconocido nuestra obligación de hacer
todo lo posible para garantizar que esto
nunca suceda otra
esta fue la última audiencia del 2022 en
la cual el comité quiso difundir sus
conclusiones antes de la nueva
legislatura el 3 de enero la mayoría
republicana que abre a partir de ese día
podría disolver este órgano y el
enjuiciamiento sería detenido finalizó
la Cumbre de la cop 15 que tuvo lugar en
la ciudad de Montreal en Canadá el
encuentro dejó un acuerdo histórico en
materia de biodiversidad nuestra
corresponsal Carolina Villa mediana
desde Montreal tiene los detalles
la madrugada este lunes se firmó en
Montreal el marco global para la
biodiversidad en el que 196 países se
comprometieron con 23 metas para frenar
el deterioro de los ecosistemas del
planeta de aquí al final de la década el
histórico acuerdo que se logra tras
cuatro años de negociaciones establece
el 30 por 30 la protección del 30% de la
superficie terrestres y acuáticas del
planeta de aquí hasta el año 2030 una
meta que sería aquí para darle al uno
punto cinco grados del acuerdo de París
en materia de cambio climático este
acuerdo también Establece que se
reduzcan los subsidios dañinos a la
naturaleza en hasta 500 mil millones de
dólares al año y la reducción a la mitad
en los desechos alimentarios y también
en los efectos nocivos de los pesticidas
para financiar estas metas se estableció
la creación de un fondo de 200 mil
millones de dólares al año provenientes
de fuentes públicas privadas nacionales
e internacionales así como también la
creación de un flujo financiero hacia
los países en vías de desarrollo de unos
30 mil millones de dólares al año la
República democrática del Congo no
estuvo de acuerdo con la aprobación de
este marco y reclamó que los recursos
que se le ofrecían a los países en vías
de desarrollo eran insuficientes para lo
ambicioso de las metas sin embargo este
comentario fue tomado como un reclamo
informal y no como una objeción formal
por lo que el acuerdo fue Igualmente
aprobado la ong ambientalistas piden que
los gobiernos comiencen a crear planes
nacionales y que los presenten antes de
la cop16 que se celebrará en Turquía en
a continuación otras noticias destacadas
de la jornada aquí en France 24
la guerrilla colombiana del eln anunció
una tregua para navidad y fin de año lo
que pone fin a un paro armado indefinido
que estaba instaurado en la región
selvática del choco que tenía confinados
acerca de 10.000 habitantes
cerca de 4,8 millones de paraguayos
estaban llamados a participar en las
primarias presidenciales de ese país
Santiago Peña representará al partido
Colorado Mientras que el liberal Efraín
alegre será candidato a la presidencia
por la llamada concertación nacional
y el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo
lasso sostuvo un encuentro oficial en la
casa blanca con el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden los mandatarios
hablaron de temas de cooperación en
seguridad economía y Comercio
y Qatar dijo Adiós tras haber sido la
sede de la Copa del Mundo controversias
críticas cerca de 17 mil millones de
dólares en ingresos y más de 1,2
millones de visitantes es parte del
balance que deja esta copa del mundo que
sigue entonces para este país de medio
oriente vamos a conversar con Julio
chiapeta él es comentaristas periodista
deportivo lo saludamos en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires Julio Bienvenido a France
24 primero que todo lo felicito por el
triunfo de la Selección Argentina y
comienzo preguntándole Cuál es el
balance que hace usted de Qatar como
sede y organizador de esta Copa del
Mundo Hola Santiago Muchas gracias este
estamos muy felices en la tierra de los
nuevos campeones del mundo de fútbol el
balance que se hace es contradictorio
creo que fue un mundial
raro pero para los argentinos tuvo un
final feliz un final de película con
un partido el último el de que nos
brinda Argentina y Francia que es una de
las mejores finales de la historia de
los mundiales por lo menos de los muchos
que yo vi en
el escenario o por televisión desde
México
1970 tuvo de todo Buen fútbol de
polémicas este jugadas impecables y
goles de maravilla como el segundo que
hizo este Di María para la Selección
Argentina y un jugador exquisito como
Lionel Messi que a quien Dios le regaló
lo que le faltaba que era besar y
levantar la copa del mundo ahora sabe
cuánto pesa ese trofeo tan ambiciado por
todos los que aman este deporte Julio
catar tuvo la oportunidad de darse aquí
visibilidad internacional toma cierta
ventaja con sus vecinos y rivales
digámoslo así estamos hablando de los
emiratos árabes Unidos de vareen los
países del Golfo Pérsico Cómo cambia la
imagen de un país después de haber sido
sede de un mundial usted tuvo la
experiencia de El caso argentino en el
78 por ejemplo
Sí por supuesto Eh bueno Ahora hay que
ver qué es lo que sale a la luz si van a
salir todas las cosas que se taparon
Durante este mundial como las denuncias
hechas por los organismos de derechos
humanos y por la
organizaciones de trabajadores este
sobre los las condiciones paupérrimas y
las muertes que hubo en la construcción
de los estadios como hablamos en
oportunidad anterior Santiago te
recuerdas o este todo se tapa con el
festejo y
la la gran este fiesta que se vivió en
cada uno de los estadios con las
elecciones que tuvieron mayor apoyo
primero fueron México Argentina después
se sumó Marruecos pero hubo muy pocos
este
fanáticos de Europa claro los europeos
le hicieron un
mundial de Qatar y no fueron en masa
como en otros mundiales sí Julio
préstame atención a esta alineación que
le voy a decir alineación de fichas como
si estábamos hablando de fútbol Messi
mbappé el psg el Emir de Qatar inversión
en este equipo francés se consolida
Entonces catar como un país importante
en la industria futbolística a nivel
internacional no en el tema competitivo
porque la selección salió en la primera
ronda pero por lo menos Sí para mover
fichas y para financiar este deporte
yo creo que ya lo hizo porque tiene
intereses en clubes en la Premier tiene
en el psg tienen el Milan Así que va a
seguir acentuando tu invasión a con
capitales en los equipos más importantes
y en las figuras más destacadas de este
deporte
Julio Chiapas Muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en France 24
un gusto Santiago conversar con vos es
siempre Saludos
así llegamos al final de las noticias
aquí en France 24 siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]